Sports Illustrated senior NBA runner
back at Sports Illustrated since the
first the month Chris Mannix right here
in studio good to see you sir how you
doing rich you're not gonna tell Dan I'm
here right well he sees everything Dan
knows everything but you know Dan
doesn't own you does he I know he owns
your your hairstyle yeah I know that I
mean I know that it feels like it's
almost eminent domain he's kind of
grabbed me and you know pulled me into
his orbit I think there's enough Maddox
to go around I'd like to think so is
what I like to think but you went you
went to fritzy's uh stand up I did I did
it was uh it was something yeah look
that's that's the gutsiest thing
somebody could do I think no question
and up there understand I would let me
just say this about it not to you know
people should go see Fritz if he does it
again whenever that may be
yes um if I didn't know Fritzi I would
have thought it was funnier but given
that I know Fritzi I know
I now know a little bit too much about
his personal life to the point where
rich I'm not sure I can ever be in the
same room with he and his wife ever
again I understand do you have do you
have the Joe Rogan line that's the
perfect an outgoing full Joe Rogan now
when you've been these day I understand
I understand I'm seeing fritzy tomorrow
I'm doing Dan show tomorrow I'll say
I'll tell him that you say hi yeah
please do that be Honda inside a report
Chris Mannix here on the Rich Eisen show
all right what do you make of the dream
on suspension is it is it something that
can tear the Warriors asunder
do you think Chris Mannix I think it's
something that could I'm with you that I
wouldn't bet on it doing it that's a far
too talented team but it's interesting
that they suspended him because a couple
of years ago draymond Green went after
Steve Kerr in a locker room in Oklahoma
City bad to be physically separated that
didn't rise to a suspension in the eyes
of Golden State Warriors management's
this does now there's a lot of questions
about why this does was it something
that draymond said in the locker room
did in the locker room that was just
different from what happened with Kerr
or you know a lot of people around the
league believe this is
kind of an olive branch to Kevin Durant
saying that look we're siding with you
on this we believe that you were in the
right
Dre mom was in the wrong we're gonna
send a mess to draymond that that was
intolerable so the Warriors aren't
saying much people behind the scenes
aren't saying much but but this is this
is different than anything Dre mods done
before well the draymond cur moment in
the locker room as it was reported again
during their championship run last year
was seen as a watershed moment for the
positive between two men the two men and
the team and the organization as a whole
that they were able to get through it
they were able to get out whatever
needed to be gotten out is there any
possibility that you see you know it's
still early on that this could be
essentially viewed in hindsight as that
as well I think it's possible because
you know draymond and KD have gone at it
before and it maintained a pretty strong
French remember was draymond that was
the the principle guy recruiting KD all
throughout his last season in Oklahoma
City but how many times can you keep
sort of doing that rich how many times
gonna keep having these blow-ups and
thinking it's going to become a positive
with this team I know there are some
veterans inside that locker room that
you know the last couple of years have
been getting a little tired of being the
adults in the room you know draymond is
a beloved teammate there's no question
about that but the the heart on your
sleeve over emotional stuff I know it
does wear on people inside that locker
room now I don't know how that manifests
itself for this year but moving forward
you know people have suggests this could
be the last year we see the last time we
see this Oakland or this Golden State
team together with Durant they may look
to move off a draymond Green after this
year they may look to do some different
things
if Kevin Durant decides to leave via
free agency which is what a lot of
people around the league believe anyway
which I can't tell you I mean I've
covered a lot of big name for agents
over the last ten years there are people
and they don't necessarily have direct
knowledge of Durant but there are people
that believe unequivocally that Durant's
gone like no question like no no way
not even a chance he goes back to gold
staff there's you smart people people I
talk to all the time that never say
stuff like this that belief
unequivocally that Kevin Durant is going
somewhere else well if those smart
people know that
Draiman grains no dummy then maybe
that's what is the base of him
reportedly talking about his impending
free agency in in the heat of a moment
of an actual NBA game that's being
played out yeah I mean in November Steve
Kerr said that you know free and said
nothing to do with it I don't really
believe that I think whatever was said
the specifics that were said behind the
scenes I think Durant's free agency is
playing into some of the tension and
that tension was kind of masked over in
the early part of the season because
they were playing great basketball I saw
them play two games in New York and the
narrative wasn't you know Durant's free
agency necessarily even when he's going
through New York it was wow you guys are
off to a better start than you were last
year Durant and Steph Carter look like
they're more in sync than ever before
they made that video the Fergie video
inside the Knicks locker room everything
is going well but I think there there
are cracks in there and are too have
been cracks in that foundation that an
incident like this certainly brings to
life and then then there's a question
Chris Maddox of Sports Illustrated here
on the Rich Eisen show there is the
question of it does that mean they don't
win this year I don't see another team
that's gonna because they are lead-pipe
wielding professionals up there in
Golden State yeah I think they do
understand maybe what they have right
now who could be the team that takes
advantage of whatever injuries that they
do suffer how long Curry's out or
whatever is going on in the locker room
doesn't get papered over doesn't get
smoothed over somehow someway whatever
happened last year in the locker room
that they were able to get past that was
revealed was actually going on after
they want who could be the team anywhere
on this NBA landscape that would be able
to take advantage in shock in the
Western Conference you don't see it
because Houston took a step back I mean
I don't know they'll turn it around in
some way they're too talented not to get
back into that playoff mix but they're
not the team that they were last year
the biggest mistake the Rockets made was
not paying Trevor Ariza and not paying
Luke moba moot a and not just bringing
the band back together there was up
three to one Golden State in that
Conference Finals after that I'm big on
Utah but I don't think Utah's ready I
think Portland would spend a lot of home
games I don't think they're on that
level yet I don't see a Western
Conference team you actually have to
look in the
stern conference which the top of he's
really good right now I mean Toronto is
legit nobody not enough people talk
about how good the Toronto Raptors are
you put Kawhi Leonard onto that team a
team of players that everybody knows
their role everybody knows exactly what
they're supposed to do and is completely
comfortable doing it you added all the
way back Kawhi Leonard to that mix there
are 60 65 win team if they stay healthy
this year I think Boston's gonna figure
it out so I think the challenge for
Golden State is not gonna come from one
of the Western Conference of opponents
but somebody that comes out of these so
then we're talking about June which
means what happens now and late in
mid-november Mike well the question I
would wonder you know do they make a
deal to not involve in one of their key
guys nobody's getting traded off that
team this year they know what they have
in Golden State but they make a deal
maybe to bring in another veteran
they've had success with you know elder
statesmen in that locker room David West
was a good example a tremendous locker
room guy that they lost a retirement
after this year did they go out and try
to recruit one of those guys you know
Peter before the trade deadline or when
they get cut via free agency to inject
some more life into that locker I don't
know I mean boogy cousins look to be the
peacemakers I mean this is this is what
we've come to I mean I kind of I wrote
something a few weeks back like you know
this Warriors team but it's not almost
sarcastically like you know they might
actually be good if they get a five-time
all-star back into the mix now it's like
we're counting on boogie cousins to be
to come back and be the stabilizing
force in that locker
boogy boogy he's the peacemaker boogie
is the guy that will make everything
okay in that mix it's having covered him
in Sacramento ad nauseum for what he
what he did out there
it's wild even think that yeah I mean
did he was doing it at that very moment
Chris Mannix here in the Honda insider
port ask him the poll question Chris
what do you have over yes so we're
looking at this drama Chris what's the
more likely scenario for the Warriors
next year
Durant gone draymond gone via trade both
gone or both back I think dad gone
easily the most likely I mean draymond
you know he's got another year on that
contract I believe so I don't think they
extend him I don't I you know he's gonna
be over 30 when that time comes to pay
him a guy like draymond that doesn't
shoot the ball well doesn't have great
size they don't age particularly well in
the
being I think the Warriors will have a
number that they want to offer dream on
it won't go any higher but you know
Durant's gonna walk away at the end of
this year most likely most likely
scenario
Durant's 30 years old he's gonna have
multiple championships under his belt
three championships under his belt and a
blank slate you know nobody can say
you've never won championships you can
do whatever you want that's why I think
New York continues to be the most likely
destination because he can go there and
we know that winning a championship in
New York would mean more than two or
three championships anywhere else they
haven't won since the early 70s they've
been so dysfunctional really for the
last two decades going to New York and
winning something would be an incredible
feather in Durance cap and he can also
mount up this means I think to him but
he could also do what LeBron James
declined to do
LeBron declined to go to New York and
take on the challenge that is the Knicks
he could go there and maybe win a
championship which LeBron did I don't
think he wants to play with LeBron
either rich people like to put him when
you you're a player not just Durant but
when you reach a certain threshold of
Championships you no longer want to be
the guy that helps LeBron win
championships you want to be the guy
that becomes the LeBron of this
generation you want to be the Kobe of
this generation the Michael this
generation you want to win the most
championships of any player in your era
that's what I think is would keep Durant
from going flossing let's talk about
this a little bit more with you Chris
Mannix is it kind of plays into a
handful of things that you know we're
already hearing Kawhi is happy that he
could be the Paul George of 2019 free
agency by staying put wherever he's been
traded to in a way that you didn't think
would be possible and then from what
you're saying Durant
would leave Golden State but to do his
own thing which would in my mind leave
Golden State showering a whole bunch of
money on klay Thompson which of
everybody here in Los Angeles says
Clay's coming here is gonna play for
daddy Michael's team and come back and
and team up with LeBron exactly the type
of player that they need in a in a
3-point challenged shooting roster are
we gonna find that nobody wants to come
and take that max contract from Magic
Johnson is that what you're saying I
think it's possible or it's someone you
don't necessarily
is worthy of the max contract you
overpay somebody maybe it's the Marcus
cousins when he hits free agency from
gold state we know he's not going back
there but the Jimmy Butler trade to
Philadelphia
you know the Sixers don't make that deal
unless they're confident they can either
bring him back or willing to give him
the 5-year deal that will guarantee that
he comes back I don't know I mean it's
way too early with Hawaii and the and
the Raptors but I've always believed
rich and I've written this that the
people around Kawhi Leonard I don't know
if they necessarily spoke for what Kawhi
Leonard wanted
I mean Kawhi has always been a guy that
just wants to win wants to get well-paid
and focus on basketball he's on a team
with a bunch of 20-somethings that he
can grow with that bench that people
probably can't name with a roster sheet
in front of them but the Pascal see out
comes the og on Adobe's these guys are
really good players and really young
players so if Kawhi Leonard is looking
at the next five seven eight years of
his career the best place for him to win
is in Toronto with the Raptors we don't
know what the Lakers gonna be the next
few years we don't know what the
Clippers are gonna be for the next few
years he has a good idea what Toronto is
gonna be that's an interesting way that
you bring up the Clippers cuz I you you
you don't need to be told about how the
NBA narrative works you clearly you're
you're part of that machine and it is a
narrative generating machine that's just
like the NFL feels the same way that
there's every something there's a drama
all the time but one way that NBA I
think outstrips the NFL is that the the
narrative that always gets sold out
there there's a sub is an undercurrent
that everybody starts talking about and
then the undercurrent usually takes you
know center stage in the same way that
nobody might want to play with LeBron
and take that max contract that the
Clippers might eventually be viewed is
the more viable choice for a free agent
to come here to do their own thing you
know match Taylor Swift for a number of
banners in in in in staples I mean I
went to the Kings game last night
there's the Laker banners all over the
place and then there's you know the the
WNBA banners up there from the LA Sparks
right and then you've got Taylor Swift's
miner there's nothing from the Clippers
in there so somebody could come to Los
Angeles and create their own whole cloth
dynasty or legacy right I think it's
it's appealing and the Clippers I think
have done
especially with their recent draft pick
Shea guild Alexander he's a player I
think he's gonna be a real player in
this league they've got a functional
organization right now the Lakers at the
moment are dealing with some dysfunction
we don't know at the end of the year if
Luke Walton is going to be that coach
Doc Rivers signed up for the long term
Lawrence Frank cinch arge there they've
got an excellent front office area West
I say I was gonna say my old colleague
Lee Jenkins now okay sorry my bad I was
told he was running now sorry I don't I
don't mean that the new logo but but
yeah but they're they're functional and
when when you talk to agents of pending
free agents one thing that's come up a
lot in the last four or five years is
the functionality of franchises like is
the coach gonna be there for the long
term is the GM entrenched at that
position ownership do they get involved
I mean the big problem Phoenix right now
is Robert Sarver who is one of the most
mettlesome hands on owners in the NBA
the Lakers are the Clippers rather
seemingly have a pretty solid base from
ownership with Steve Ballmer to Lawrence
Frank to Doc Rivers and everything in
between that means a lot
the Knicks this year their big pitch to
Kevin Durant isn't look at Mitchell
Robinson he's a great player or come
play with Frank Neal akina
porzingis may not even come back this
season they don't care with that all
they want to do is look functional to
have Scott Perry lead their front office
and David phys Dale be their head coach
can we send can we send JD out with a
straight shot then how about he and and
and the unicorn soft spaces we send we
send Dolan with the straight shot to
Eastern Europe go on a tour go go see
where lamella hung out and then you know
bring the purple unicorn back can we do
that you're notified about JD
ministration
please last one for you here last 140
Chris Mannix what was Dwayne Wade
referring to when he said that Carmelo
Anthony was being the scapegoat and we
all know what the real thing is here I
haven't gotten a straight answer on that
what was he referring to I don't I don't
know what exactly he was referring to
it's either the owner I mean it's either
the general manager the coach or Harden
who is it
yes if I had to guess I would say Harden
it always comes down to the
I mean that's just a guess on my part
sure but when I saw that tweet and was
asking people about it most people said
it's it's just more of a full-throated
defense of Carmela like Carmelo has a
lot of friends in the NBA even the
places he doesn't work out New York
Oklahoma City now Houston everybody
likes him all the players in the locker
room want to play with him the Oklahoma
City guys were just like it just didn't
work with Paul George and Russell
Westbrook alongside him so he has got a
lot of allies in the league and this
notion it's out there rich of he should
retire or it's his fault or he can't
adjust to a secondary role some of that
stuff may be true but it doesn't change
the perception of crime Alex why I think
Carmelo is not gonna retire he's gonna
wind up either in Miami with Dwayne Wade
or Portland with the Blazers and
continue to try to make something of the
final chapter of his career alright last
one for you I lied because they're
philly.com just reported out of
Philadelphia Fults is coming off the
bench radek's is started with Butler's
first games that surprised you what do
you think he should have been coming off
the bench all along I mean the strategy
of playing Marc Hill folks with the
starters they had a bizarre strategy I
mean I was at a couple of Sixers games
this season they play Fultz as many
minutes as they can the first half and
then because they can't rely on him he
plays like somebody who plays three five
seven in that second half if you're
gonna rebuild Markel fullest confidence
you have got to put him in a position to
succeed as the primary ball handler he
was never gonna be that guy with
Philadelphia because Ben Simmons has the
ball in his hands and certainly not with
a high usage rate guy like Jimmy Butler
in that lineup I think this is a gift
for the Sixers if they hope to read to
kind of rediscover rebuild marquel
floats which I'm not sure as possible in
Philadelphia this with the second unit
is the best way to do it Congrats and
getting back in Sports Illustrated thank
you rich let me check my phone is Dan
texted uh you're in the clear right now
I am okay yeah none of the Danites have
text either so I think it's good we have
to shave my head again hey look man if
you went to see Fritz do stand-up comedy
yours I mean you're you're part of
daeviation we all understand that but
you're there's enough Mannix to go
around there is certainly in the Honda
inside a report which is brought to you
by our friends again at the 2019 Honda
Accord with sleek styling a
sophisticated interior and standard
Honda sensing the Accord is a gift that
keeps on giving this holiday season so
hurry to the happy Honda days sales
event for a great deal today at s I
Chris Mannix on Twitter great to see you
man let me know that you're in town
come back anytime will do you bet the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience